well I guess I'll start hi everyone
have a good afternoon welcome my name is
M grass meter or Emma grass meter
sometimes I'm the thoughtworks Germany
data which and yeah my background is in
it started out in I have a religion
degree but I went to grad school to
study experimental economics where I
learned a lot of statistics and game
theory and data analysis skills and then
when I dropped out I went on to become a
data scientist which I've been doing for
the last several years so that's a
little bit about me this is my colleague
Jin hi I work as a senior consultant at
ThoughtWorks
so I've been doing on several software
projects but on in my personal time I'm
doing more projects focusing on machine
learning and AI yeah previously I have
industry experience in banking yeah cool
so we're gonna talk a moment about we
have to do the talking about that works
for like two seconds so just that works
Germany has 250 people we are
consultants and technologists we help
people if you need to turn break your
silos down and create a data lake or if
we need to help train people in agile
methodology or do test-driven
development we love that stuff and so we
help people do that and we also very
much care about keeping things out in
the open so that workers are people who
write books that workers are people who
push the industry for better standards
or for better Purdue practices and so
that's why what we're talking about
today has been we've made it an open
source resource that will show you the
link for in a second but yeah so we're
trying to basically we're here to teach
people how to get started on their very
first data science project we're going
to talk about a problem statement and
then we're going to explore the entire
machine learning pipeline that we've set
up it's a pretty basic simple story but
this isn't like this is an experience
for people who have sort of no
experience doing machine learning no
experience putting something into
production
that's machine learning at all
and yeah so do you want to go over the
agenda point-by-point er cool okay so
the problem that we want to solve is
demand forecasting so we want to predict
item sales for a supermarket in Ecuador
so to get a better sense of problem
let's let me introduce the data so we
have a train data of some items daily
sales for foreign half years and then we
have a 4,000 different items and it
involves 50 different stores and there
are 125 million different transaction
data metadata so our goal is to predict
how many of each product will be
purchased in each store on each day of
next two weeks so let's think about
let's let's think how to approach our
problem of demand forecasting of
predicting item sales for a supermarket
so they are about so we want to apply
machine learning to solve this problem
so there are about three types of
machine running on do you know what they
are
yeah yeah III already here no here are
the answers
yeah and great yeah so they are on
supervised learning unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning so
what is a supervised learning about
mm-hmm yeah yeah right yeah so in
supervised learning or we have a target
which can be value or class and we want
to predict predict this target or based
on input so it's about finding a
function approximation mapping input to
output and oh and unsupervised learning
and it's on the contrary it doesn't have
a target or we have unlabeled data and
then we want to a group data into into
similar ones so it's more about our
finding compact data description and
reinforcement learning or is very
different we only have objective and
then there are specific rules describing
the environment and then we want to find
the best strategy to optimize the
objective and it's it's it's like a game
play you play many games and then you
want to find the best of strategy so so
let's come back to our problem so which
which approach is applicable to our
problem yes correct
yeah so our problem is relevant to
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning or it's about finding on
finding function or mapping from input
to output but then also what what should
be output in our problem
yeah yeah so the future sales number of
item in a store yeah on a specific day
and then or like what should be the
input so actually oh it's going to be
the focus of our own main session so is
we are going to do data exploration and
feature engineering to find a better
representation of X so it's time to get
started we made this as a github
repository so if you want to you can we
recommend ya go to go to github and go
ahead and clone this repository that
works Inc /t wde data lab and so what
what we're doing is if you install and
then run this first file you will
download several different data sets
from an s3 bucket and then denormalize
them and smush them all together and
create the we call it the like pretty
dumb way we call it the big table which
has all of the data that we might
consider in this session so go ahead and
start doing this now we're also going to
come around and pass around thumb drives
if people just want the data or the
repository if the Internet's not working
so we're gonna leave this slide up I'm
gonna put the mic down and we're gonna
make sure that everybody goes through
this and can run merger dot py on their
computers right now and so just get our
attention somehow if you're having
trouble with that
should I
thumb drives are going around people
already have some so if you need one
just raise your hand and yeah hopefully
we can get some
the thumb drives have the repository and
the end data that comes out as a result
of running Python merger dot py but it
doesn't have the requirements like if if
you need the required packages to
actually run require a merger dot py
those requirements you actually need to
download from the Wi-Fi that we have and
if so yeah we're gonna explain what
merger that py is doing but basically
it's taking several different data
sources like different tables that have
been isolated just like you would
basically set up an SQL sec wait go
ahead or share them to other people yeah
merge it up py is denormalizing the data
to make it ready to consume in a machine
learning algorithm
is there nothing we can
we had a question about the requirements
that txt
you don't need the specific versions
that are mentioned there that was I
think what was current when we made the
repository but if you have those
packages in another version it should
probably work mostly what we're going to
do today is is do per notebook and
pandas data exploration
[Music]
usually so usually at this part of the
presentation we make sure that every
single person in the room is able to run
the entire data science pipeline on
their machine
I don't know how scalable that will be
or how well it's scaled to this yeah so
how many people are ready to run Jupiter
notebook on their machines right now
that's a decent amount so if you can't
do that because this is like mostly
gonna be y'all working so if you can't
do that can you find somebody who is
like any moving around to find a pair
will be fun but is it possible to find a
pair can we can we put people who
absolutely can't get Jupiter notebook
running to find somebody who can
that would require actually standing up
and talking with people this is like a
thing that this is gonna work people are
going to get next to each other and talk
to each other and brainstorm about
things that's like an integral part of
the data science process
[Music]
who doesn't have Jupiter notebook and
won't be able to do data exploration on
their own machines raise your hand high
this isn't a shame thing this is like a
man I can't do this yet this is because
my computer is not letting me okay can
we can people keep your hands up if you
cannot do jupiter notebook on your
machine like it's yeah if you've never
done it before then you probably can't
like you don't have it
can somebody invite these people who
don't have jupiter notebook yet over to
them so that they can pair with you so
who wants who wants this person right
here okay we got up here you didn't have
one you but we can get you the data who
else needs stupider notebook or somebody
with jupiter notebook i know there's
more
[Music]
are there any people who still have
thumb drives that are available can we
get that one down here
the free thumb drive over here
[Music]
so so we are going to proceed I hope
people find someone on for whom things
are working so that that was the data on
a subset data because it's a it's a data
of stores in quito area yeah cool so but
yeah so if you need the data keep like
raising your hand or looking around and
if you have a thumb drive that's free
like raise your hand up and we'll come
and give it to the people who need it so
cool to explain the machine learning
pipeline cool this is kind of the layout
that we set up this is exactly the
layout that we set up for our machine
learning pipeline what and each of these
like the green things are artifacts and
the blue things are actions that we're
taking and these are we actually have
different Python files for each of these
blue squares in the in the chart but so
basically this merger dot py which I
don't think anybody would be able to get
to work what it does is it goes to s3
and it downloads different tables which
have different specific pieces of
information and it merges them it
basically does a left outer join on a
certain column so we could use the date
for example if we had a whole bunch of
data actually we can go to the next
slide and talk about that so what merger
py is going to do is it's going to take
your like some data that we were given
from the from the client from the
grocery store and it's going to take
some external piece of data set for
example the I don't know the price of
oil for this during the time period that
we're talking about or the Consumer
Price Index for the time period that
we're talking about and it's going to
add that new piece of data like the
consumer price index on the day the
table that we already have so that every
time every data point that we have given
a certain day
we'll be merged on to this one
agglomerate giant data table that's
being developed which we called big big
table so this is a process of D
normalization and the reason that we do
this is because this bottom table with
like all of it's sort of weird
redundancies like couldn't if we're
gonna be like good database
administrators we could probably extract
out this like redundancy of the state
and the city and the cluster and like
there's a bunch of repeated information
and this it's very inefficient way of
storing data but this is the way that
machine learning algorithms like to
consume their data for the most part so
that's why we're doing this that's why
we're smashing them all together so
these are the these are the data from
the desert information from the raw data
but we might consider designing more
features because the so the data is like
time series data but then we want to you
want to represent or you want to you
want to be on to design data or to fit
the supervised learning cool so the next
step in that flowchart is to split the
data and the reason that we do that is
because we want to have some way to
prevent overfitting our data and making
sure that we are making our predictions
in an unbiased way that we're not
getting stuck in some weird local optima
and preventing ourselves from thinking
that we're doing a great job when we
might actually once we get more data we
might find that our model only works for
the time frame that we're talking about
or that we've already seen so the way
that overfitting works is when you try
to make a model one of the simplest
models that you could think of is it as
a linear regression or maybe a
polynomial regression that's a little
bit more complex but these linear and
polynomial regressions create a model
that tries to map out the data and a
linear regression on this first tab you
can see it's doesn't describe the data
very well it's
most it's never gonna be exactly where
or it might it has like an
infinitesimally small chance of being
right about any particular data point
but it doesn't even to the human eye you
can see that this doesn't describe the
data correctly if we skip the second one
and come over to the third this model is
describing the data that we have
perfectly every single point we've
accounted for and it's just like a
perfect representation of the data that
we already have but it's like a is a
terrible representation of the data in
general because if we were to imagine if
we got another point say like we got
another another data point further along
the x-axis what's the likelihood of this
Jaggi line actually representing the
next data point that comes it's it's not
showing a trend it's just mapping to the
data perfectly and the next data point
is likely going to follow the trend but
we can't have Matt like that if the
behavior outside of the time frame of
this model is undefined that's why this
model in the middle is a really good
representation of the data if we were to
get another data point someplace we
would still be describing like it would
fit into the model pretty well as well
as it has been so far so yes we haven't
actually touched to any of these points
we haven't predicted anything perfectly
but we're predicting it generically in a
very good way so the point of doing of
splitting the data is to do to to be
used in a validation strategy so that we
can actually make sure that we have an
overfit our data and then the next step
in this data science pipeline is to
actually train your model and the reason
that I included this this is how much
code if you've never done it before this
is how much Python code it takes to
actually make like do machine learning
you just like throw some data if you
throw one data frame in you throw
another data frame in BAM you have a
model now you can ask it a question
it'll give you an answer it takes like
ten lines of code to do machine learning
but that's not the hard part so there
are ways that we can tweak the data or
we can tweak the algorithm there are
important choices about choosing
algorithm but a lot of this can be made
independent of how you prepare the data
and can be made as an ongoing iterative
process and so the reason that we we
don't focus on that in this presentation
we're focusing on the more sciency part
of actually exploring the data and
understanding what information to give
to the machine learning algorithm and
even if we when we've chosen the right
data to give to the machine learning
algorithm we can swap out algorithms and
try something new or we can try to
parameterize or algorithm differently
but the work that we've done choosing
and preparing the data correctly is
going to be useful
regardless most likely so here's it
again start out with a lot of different
data sets plug it in to unlike join them
together with the merger and now we have
this big table the big table is the
thing on the thumb drive that's coming
around so everybody now has big big
table on your computer someplace we
don't need to you don't need the merger
that py file if you already have this
big table then we split it to make sure
that we can check out we can assess the
efficacy of our of our algorithm we
train the model and then we look to see
how well our predictions stand against
the actual values we could do a whole
presentation a bit about validation of
data of algorithms but we're talking
about data exploration and feature
engineering today so do you want to talk
about exploratory analysis or should I
I'll keep going so the purpose of
exploratory analysis is to understand
the data that you have to ask questions
about like what are these what are these
anomalies mean what is this actual value
that looks pretty normal mean and then
to also be able to communicate your
findings with your stakeholders or your
colleagues or yourself in the future to
squeeze out more information to give
your algorithm a little bit of a hint
and yeah basically to know about the
next store to know what to do for the
next step which is feature engineering
this is part of so this is I was just
doing some exploratory analysis and this
came from the data that set that we're
talking about this is a graph of the
median return rate so what we're talking
about is negative sales that happened in
our in art like across the entire year
of our dataset so there's obviously
something different about like there's
something that stands out can anybody
tell me what stands out about this data
set so the thing is January December so
before I was able to do this I had to
ask the question what is a negative sale
like what does that even mean my data
set says unit sales and then there's
like a bunch of negative numbers so what
the hell does that mean it turns out if
you've worked in sales that might mean
like you might know that that might mean
things have been broken things have been
stolen
or things have been returned those are
negative sales in the retail world so
when you look at this and you know that
these this is a graph of things that
have been broken stolen or returned we
have this question of why is there this
huge spike down in January or just at
the beginning of January or the end of
December so the answer is Christmas this
is this is like maybe right after
Christmas we could make a hypothesis
that right after Christmas people are
returning gifts that they didn't want or
that or whatever or maybe I we don't
have exactly the granularity to know if
maybe this was people stealing things
before Christmas or breaking things
while they're fighting on Black Friday
we could we could ask that question
which of these things is happening by
looking at the data a little bit deeper
you want to talk about this one yeah so
this is another interesting example
there you might find in
or data exploration so this is the graph
of daily unit sales for a specific item
in a specific store of the year 2016 on
in October so so they say this is a unit
sales of one month and then looking at
this graph graph like what kind of
hypothesis or you you want to do you
want to make what do you notice
yeah we have a hand yeah so I think I
heard on weekends we have higher sales I
can't maybe tell buy I don't know which
day zero is but yeah in any case there's
a cyclical yeah yeah so like you might
find some seasonality in terms of
weekday so you want to consider like a
day of the week in your features yeah so
the question is what do we do when we
know that there's like something
obviously weird going on around
Christmas or what do we do and we know
that there's something obviously like
there's a cyclical pattern throughout
the week how do we how do we tell our
data science our machine learning
algorithm
hey this is happening like if we give it
enough data points eventually it might
figure that that cyclical pattern out
but there's ways to help the algorithm
along so that's what feature engineering
is that's where you you can better
represent your data by showing that
showing more features or different
features to the algorithm and this you
could also do things like reframe their
time series data in a different way
depending on what type of algorithm
you're using yeah so like actually this
is interesting or a problem that we I
mean like when we think about how to
reframe time series data for supervised
learning and like what kind of strategy
or can you think of like also time there
is a time series data but then we want
to represent
like you want to represent as one data
point on who to predict in order to
predict future sales of a specific day
or a specific item first in a specific
store yeah I mean so yeah we can you can
think about it more and then I want to
emphasize that if we make good features
it can you can already serve a baseline
model so baseline model means you don't
actually have to use or complicated
machine learning on algorithm so you
know like I mean machine learning
algorithm is often effective but then or
sometimes we don't know what's going on
inside
but then or to have for our sanity check
it's nice to have like some baseline
number that you can compare with the
result of your machine learning
algorithm that your machine learning is
actually doing enough work we have a
question over there oh yeah so it's yeah
it's in one of the following slides we
are getting the Arizona yeah thank you
cool so yeah what we're doing today is
we're going to do data exploration with
the goal in mind of someday adding
features or changing features changing
the input that we give our machine
learning algorithm it's an iterative
process and this is why it's good to
pair on things yeah that's what's coming
ahead I don't know what else is on this
life and the question of how do we do it
we do it with Jupiter notebooks we do it
with pandas you search for something on
the internet like pandas cheat sheet if
you've never used it if you've never
used pandas before you don't know how to
look at a specific column you don't know
how to compare columns you also ask your
your neighbor because somebody in here
probably knows the answer to whatever
thing you're trying to do and we don't
need to do that because that definitely
won't work so ignore the W get part and
just go and bring up Jupiter notebook
the way that I do it on my macbook is I
type in Jupiter a space notebook and
it'll bring
a new browser tab or a new browser so go
ahead and do ignore the first step but
do the other two things right now so
probably in terminal probably wherever
you have downloaded Jupiter notebook and
remember everyone nobody raised their
hand when they didn't have jupiter
notebook so i know everyone has it bring
up jupiter notebook and create a new
Python it doesn't have to be Python 3
create a new Python notebook and we can
start looking at the data does anybody
wanting one of those pairs right now
does anybody want somebody who knows
who's more familiar with Jupiter
notebook we can try to pair you up
together
cool yeah
so are we ready to go I guess if we
didn't have to download anything
okay I think we can so wherever you've
saved this big table that came off the
thumb drive you need to import pandas
and do a read CSV with a local path
pointing to wherever that data file is
stored so this part yeah you do import
pandas as PD then you'll save a data
frame which is equal to PD dot read CSV
and then the local path to your big data
dot CSV file so go ahead and do this now
and this will be the first step and then
we can yeah break out of the groups
so what we're doing here is we're we're
opening up a brand-new notebook and not
an existing file and we're going to like
this isn't part of the this is happening
in parallel or aside from the pipeline
that exists so the splitter dot py and
things like that
those are useful when we're putting
things into production but this step is
helping us know how to split and what
and how to merge and how to what to put
into the machine learning algorithm but
not part of the actual production
pipeline so you'll open up a new file
and then load the data yourself
silly load around a little bit and was
like
so it seems like one of the thumb drives
had some corrupt data if anybody's
getting an issue parsing and like
something on line 34 we can get you the
right data
[Music]
[Music]
so who else needs that the data again
because the data was corrupted on theirs
we have two people over there anybody
else need a thumb drive again okay we
need to get it to you and you anyone
else up there and there's a thumb drive
over there can you pass it down to these
two people or okay
[Music]
or actually Shogun I mean so if you
manage to load the data they think about
these example questions and they of
course make more questions in your mind
and try to explore the data and even
think about like what which feature is
going to be helpful to predict future
sales
and if you find the thumb drive that's
got the bad data on it get it let me
know
okay so at this point if you have the
data on your machine and you've pulled
it up into Jupiter notebook you might
have typed in that last command that we
had recommended or something else that
that was that you found on the the
pandas cheat sheet that looks
interesting to you like maybe I always
look at the head just like what's the
top of this data look like what columns
do we have maybe I type in P D or D F
that columns and so I already got a
question the the question was what does
day-off mean we have a column called a
day-off and this is exactly the process
of data exploration you look at the data
you find some things that don't make
sense you ask what it means you do some
research to answer that question
sometimes research is asking somebody
who knows the answer or sometimes that
you have to go do a sociological study
of Ecuador to figure out what exactly is
going on there
so in this data set we include something
called days-off do we also include the
days off observed or the holidays
observed I don't remember but so there's
day of week which maybe is what you are
actually seeing but we also might have
holidays in there and there is a
difference between in Ecuador there's a
difference between a holiday that's like
this is the official day according to
the religion or according to the
Constitution or whatever and this is the
day when we actually don't have to go to
work so if there's like a holiday and
holiday observed column maybe we took it
out but that's what that would mean so
either you're looking at day of week or
there's something about there's the
actual holiday and then there's the day
when people don't have to work because
of the holiday that's an example so what
other questions do people have of this
data as you as you look at it the type
of some of the types of questions that
you might want to be asking are for
example what is the actual time frame of
this data we told you I think we said it
was four years but I don't know if
that's actually true because we might be
using a subset of the data so what is
like how many days are we actually
looking at
which item type is sold the most is
another question that you could start
out like you have note you're basically
we've we've planned to do on a foreign
like an another planet and you have to
go explore this planet and understand
where the dangers are where the
confusing things are you have to figure
out if gravity still works you have to
figure out what are the parameters of
this data so some of the obvious
questions just like what is the shape
like what does it look like if I if I
just look at the distribution of sales
or of like looking at a specifics or
stores sales so we looked at the example
of sales following a weekly cycle and we
looked at the seasonality effect of
Christmas so this is your time to get
familiar a little bit with the data and
then I would like some some questions
from y'all about what what questions do
you have of the data and what will you
try to learn from the data today does
anyone already have questions that they
want to know of either of what the data
means like what is this column mean or
like something that they want to explore
in the next 30 minutes or so yeah
sure what so the question was what does
CPI mean and CPI is the economic
measurement called the Consumer Price
Index this is I think it's like the cost
of a bundle of goods in 1970 I know it
doesn't matter where it's set to but
it's basically how much does bread and
milk and maybe a car just like a bunch
of consumer goods that might be
representative of the expenses of the
average person and then as that goes up
or down like wages will go up and down
and but real it's kind of a measurement
of real wage as compared to the nominal
wage which is just a number that
depending on inflation and other things
might mean different things
any other questions what other things do
people want to know about the data set
or either in like actual hey this is
confusing you set this up poorly
questions or questions that you want to
know from a from a data science
exploration process yeah what is the the
class called feet there's a feature
called cluster do you remember what that
means that was yeah I think the feature
cluster in the big table is category of
stores so this giant supermarket chain
like they have several classes of stores
like a high class and like a middle
class discount stores so yeah so and
it's possible because we wanted to make
this doable for most people in a
conference on their computers that
there's only one cluster represented it
might only be that one but yeah it's
okay so there's a day off which is a
boolean
okay so the day off would be that it's a
it's officially a holiday where nobody
is working the day of the week I don't
remember if it starts it you could have
it starts it what
but is it started on Monday or does it
start on Sunday that would be a question
that you could probably figure out with
the other columns so but yes it means
okay yeah
but the day of the day of week being a
number means that like Monday is zero
and Sunday is seven or maybe it's modulo
+1 I don't remember yeah how does one
deal with non numeric data
Jun do you want to talk about yeah so it
depends on machine learning so for some
machine learning you have to convert a
non numeric data to numeric data so
there are like two approaches that I can
think of so you can just like assign
arbitrary numbers to categorical data or
you can do if you want to be more strict
you can do like one hut-hut code
encoding yeah so not hard coding coding
is is is better because you are not
giving arbitrary ordering to to non
numeric data but then it might be it
might get very big if you have many
categories so you encode it to make it
look like a number that represents the
string that it yeah
other questions
we could make people present that would
be fun so are there any is there any
person who might want to talk about
their findings I mean we don't have yes
okay
was that a did somebody want to talk
about something they found in the data
maybe maybe later
okay then so I I want to give you like
maybe more hint so what might be
findings relevant to feature engineering
so you might have realized that there
there is different amount of data
available for item store item store and
in the worst case you might not have any
data for a specific pair and if you
don't have you don't have data available
like oh what what are you going to do
like for the missing data for example if
you don't have our own promotion data
like what what would be the value that
you use you can see a lot so on
promotion means literally it means it
the item was on promotion on the date so
if the data is not available what would
be the good default value oh yeah this
is boolean so the question is we have
this column that says is the is the good
was it unpromoted on the day that it was
like on the day that we have data for
and sometimes it's yes sometimes it's
like no but sometimes there's just no
value which doesn't necessarily mean
it's not on sale what do we do about
that I saw a hand up there what did you
want to say
yeah yeah mm-hmm yeah yeah we also agree
that that is a reasonable default value
on promotion as false if it's not
available but that's a huge assumption
that's I mean yeah it's to just really
every row that we don't have data for a
certain column okay yeah yeah so you can
you can try it like several things like
yeah and then you can be iterative you
can come back and then try to try order
of approach yeah so that suggestion was
to put some sort of weight or another
column that says we don't know if this
was on promotion but we can make a guess
did you have a
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that was to
assign randomly or given some model
based on the data that we already have
yeah that might also work and then if
you need sales is not available like
what what would you what do which value
would you use
so there's missing data and the unit
sales number yeah so hold on I heard I
heard average but this guy does he end
up first
so to impute 8 based on the mean value
but then the mean of what across the
entire year the mean of the sales across
the entire year
right so that would be in a suggestion
to do it without a weight on the present
yeah actually yeah so we we had
experience of exploring the data and
then actually we used that approach for
our baseline model but then it turns out
that our default value unit sales as
zero is turned out to be better so it's
instead the most of missing data almost
coming from small small sale number
items and to do a mean across the entire
data set is not necessarily a bad idea
it's it depends on the data it depends
on how actually predictive it is yeah
so the question was are there hints in
the data about which method you should
use for dealing with missing data I
think that's about validation so yeah
for for that purpose we just for that
purpose we are splitting data into
training data and validation data yeah
so but sometimes sometimes it's tricky
like or to get ideally we want to have
validation that is as similar as
possible to test the data but sometimes
it might be difficult especially for a
time series data like how do you know
like this two-week period is similar to
the neighboring two-week period so so
that is a challenging yeah and then you
want to talk about how to reframe time
series data for supervised learning so
like all do you have any ideas so yeah
right yeah yeah so so consider that on
WE so we want to predict why is the
future sales and then what we have
available is historical data so like a
lot is good way to summarize historical
data any ideas
statistics oh yeah who's that bad okay
great actually I'm going to talk about
talk a little bit more about that yeah
and then are we we have a seasonal
seasonality so we want you want to
consider like at least weekday pattern
on because I got data exploration we so
like a cycle in unit sales so I want to
talk about a moving average a little bit
more so
so moving average it might be good
feature to add especially for reframing
time series data to supervised learning
so so this is the example of showing
like what moving average like implies so
we have this blue line which is rotated
very jiggly and then we have on you have
green line which is a five day moving
average so we are on your average in for
the last five days and then you can see
that green line is smoother than the raw
data but then if you look at 20-day
moving average then you can see it is
even smoother than the five day moving
average so you can consider it like
roughly our short short-term trend and
long-term trend and then you don't you
can include even more more kinds of
window size and then you can include
them in features and then for weekday
average yeah so to reflect weekday
parents you might also want to consider
weekday average and then if you if you
have like this kind of if you design
many kinds of pictures then then you
might also consider what to pick a good
baseline prediction so like as I said
like for baseline prediction like you
don't have to know you don't have to
apply machine learning algorithm so you
can already guess like without any
machine learning algorithm what would be
the best guess so do you want to try a
little bit more like in this direction
and then all
so yeah so now is some more time to ask
questions of the data it's does anybody
I guess before we let you do that a
little bit more does anybody have more
questions about what does this column
mean or what does this feature talking
about in the data set
cool so then I would let Jo like talk
amongst yourselves and try to ask
questions of the data ask figure out if
there's a an interesting thing about
produce items or and seasonality or or
whatever like sort of questions and
hypotheses that you have about the data
go try to dig into that and talk to your
neighbors and ask them questions about
how to perform certain operations on
data frames or whatever you need and
then we'll come back and talk about what
your questions have been and what you've
learned about the data in that time so
now it's time for it to roam around
throughout the data and of course if you
have questions just raise your hand and
we can talk about them
so I have a I got a question how to get
moving average averages in this data so
actually I see like a couple of ways
available so so you can convert date
column two to date datatype and then
then there is like on non-p like there's
like time delta - there's like time
delta and then you can just you can just
+ - time delta to get the to move the
days or actually are in the big data in
the big table there's already in the
second in the second way there's already
Colin or called the days until end of
date
so that already shows like which the
distance from from the last date so yeah
you can you can use that to filter
filter the data for like on moving
average of a specific window size
so so the problem is to predict the item
sales of the following two-week period
from there from the last state of
training data so one data point that we
want to predict is for item specific
item specific store and specific date so
the date is the following two-week
period after the training day after the
train data
yeah a date here
so yeah if you like to succeed getting
various moving averages averages and
then weekday average then I mean what
would it be a good baseline prediction I
you might want to like you might want to
give a weight of weekday versus like the
total mean and then and then you know
that that multiplied by the median of
the various moving averages for example
so you can try on several approaches and
then if you want to do evaluation like
how how effective your approach is then
you'd better use metric so this is so
this is like one metric that you can use
and so I had its predicted prediction
and then plain Y is a true value and
then this is how you measure all the the
errors of your prediction and then our W
W is the weight which is it is bigger
for perishable items so this might be
one of the things you could use to
validate your hypothesis that we should
put zeros for the like any missing data
we'll just make a zero or a false and
then you could use this in their
validation strategy to to see if it
makes the the error term a lower number
so I have this in almost all of my
slides that if you didn't know there is
an algorithm that can help you choose
which algorithm you want to choose so
the scikit-learn documentation is
beautiful and you can read it like a
text book which we all read textbooks
like regular books straight you can
learn a lot of amazing things in this I
could learn documentation and quite
deeply understand how the algorithms
work but at first pass if you're if
you're wondering which machine learning
algorithm do I want to use in my data
science pipeline
after I know how to I know how to join
all the data together I know how to use
it
split the data for a good validation
strategy but that one part about using
the machine learning algorithm this is a
decent place to start and then you can
get at least an MVP out there you can
swap in or swap out an algorithm if you
choose like actually my data is a little
bit more something a little bit more
that like appropriate it's a more
appropriate for a certain different
algorithm you can choose later but the
important part is to get an deeper
understanding of your data and to start
putting your pipeline together and get
something that's productionize dabble
and then we can worry about exactly
which algorithm to go for later so here
it is again this is the the pipeline
that we've proposed for you each of
these could be I guess you could have
these each's in AWS lambda that's you
could put it in the data science
pipeline on AWS and basically yeah so
the part that we have been working on is
nowhere on this graph but it will
definitely help you in your merging if
say we want to add a new thing we think
the CPI is a bad bad piece of data to
use for some reason and we really just
will only care about the price of cheese
so we can add a new table that just
cares about the price of cheese in the
in the world or something if we want to
add new data we put it into this because
of our data and because of our feature
engineering and data exploration
findings we can put this new data set up
at the top on our s3 bucket and when we
and then we can modify our initial
emerging file to now consider this new
table that we've added and that will
inform our the rest of the pipeline so
that when we throw it into the training
step maybe we'll have a better output so
now we can talk if you have questions
either about the data or about the
process or about putting things into
pipelines we have seven minutes left for
questions that people want to talk
Wow cool okay a question
yes so the question is a about s3
buckets and and what is that so
this is s3 is a service provided by
Amazon that it's just a storage service
it's basically you can put files and
destroy them relatively cheaply but you
don't have to certainly you don't have
to use Amazon all of the cloud providers
provide are about at the like they can
some of them have better is one thing or
another thing but we're at the point
where if you're using Google or if
you're using Amazon or whatever you're
using it's probably gonna be pretty good
for the whatever you're going for s3 is
just what I'm experienced with and so I
usually just throw all my data up there
and the way that that pipeline would
work can we go back one side the way
that it would work is you can store all
the data like store the training data on
s3 download it when your so your
algorithm will download it and then
store this new table in another place on
s3 and then when you split it you can
that could again put out a new artifact
that's stored on s3 and this is where
you can kind of version your data you
can also upload your latest model that
is created in the training section and
store a new model and so basically if
you get some weird output you can know
like so I used this version of the data
and this version of the algorithm and
for some reason it gave me wonky results
or I'm predicting poorly so you can kind
of do a retrospective on what actually
happened given those different versions
whereas I think often when you just do
it in a in a notebook I can a lot of in
a jupiter notebook or something if
something starts doing something new you
don't have written down history of where
what was the data looking like at the
time and what was the model looking like
at the time
so you can pickle models with or you can
save you can export models from pandas
and you can save that file wherever you
want to and then load it up again I
think it's just like to pickle like did
it like model dot to pickle or something
does anybody know the actual it's asked
like ask Google how do you pickle a
model or if it's not too big you can use
CSV or zip zip file know that yeah if
that works other questions
okay so I guess we can show that Thank
You spine mm-hmm thank you
[Applause]